uh White to play made into this is a
puzzle for our viewers let's see how
quickly you can get it I'm gonna start
the timer now okay made in choose you
can usually find my process of
elimination
a few moments later
yeah usually uh
time pressure
I just wanna I just wanna solve it
[Music]
are you sure
it's hard to be yeah but Queen D4 takes
away the D4 squares the rookie 3 is made
otherwise it's Knight D6 or Knight C5 is
that it is that your final answer
I mean are you trying no yeah that is
hold on you got it in about less than
two minutes not bad it's nice huh yeah
it's really nice but it's typical it's
actually it's actually typical of these
fossils